hello everyone and welcome back to the
Lindo rossabi rapid challenge finals
it's the third match and it's the third
game of the third match dubov is in the
lead and now he has the white pieces
with against Nakamura and now he only
basically needs to draw the next two
games and he is victorious in the match
so let's see what he will do will he
mixed it up with something else or will
he try something else
so a doob of once again with the white
pieces goes for c4 he goes for his
English and Nakamura again goes for e5
we have Knight to c3 Knight to c6 and
the knight to f3 but instead of the four
Knights instead of the four Knights of
the English Nakamura goes for f5 and it
seems that Nakamura also wants to get
some winning chances with black as well
not just trying to get a draw in the
third game and then going for a win in
the fourth game with the white pieces so
du Bois goes for d4 invites efore and
the Nakamura goes for it will be for
attacking the knight and the Knight to
g5 now we have Bishop to b4 at
developing and pinning this Knight here
and the d5 we have Knight to e5 by
Nakamura and now there is one game in
the database where Queen to b3 was
played or rather where Queen to d4 was
played but in this game Queen to b3 is
played and it is already as a move 7
that we have a completely new game so
Nakamura has to do something about this
Bishop being under attack you could
defend it or you could move back at the
bishop or maybe even a5 Nakamura decides
to go back with the Bishop to brush up
the c5 and now you there could be some
problems here with the f2 pawn so double
just brings this knight back so it's not
no longer a target here as you do want
to play e3 and also it defends the f2
point for the moment so Knight to f6
Hikaru
who wants to finish development castle
the king and so on and the knight stay
for now by do both attacking the bishop
forcing get away from such an active
square so Bishop to e7 and now Bishop to
f4 attacking the knight Knight to g6 and
now while you could go back to g3 you do
have a nice coverage of the f4 square
with the bishop in the night so you
don't lose the bishop or anything but h5
could be very annoying
going for h4 so here Du Bois finds a
very interesting v6 move which which
messes up a white pawn structure in the
center and really weakens the d5 square
so Nakamura grabs it C captures on d6
and now just nice to see three bring him
back the night into the game and
Nakamura immediately goes back with it
to d5 trying to trying to give back the
pawn
however III buy dubov he just opens up
his light square bishop if Nakamura
captures or anything he can just
recapture in the Nakamura will not be
able to castle so Nakamura castles right
away and now rook to d1 putting more
pressure on the d5 pawn and now d6 and
Nakamura not interested in material here
he wants to get his pieces developed so
Bishop to e2 anubhav also prepares the
castle in now h6 we have castles by do
both and Bishop to e6 now now again
preparing to capture on c4 so here we do
have a capture so Knight captures here
and Bishop captures on d5 Nakamura
decides that the the knight would be
more valuable here than the light square
bishop so si captures on d5 and Queen to
b6 now Nakamura offers the trade here I
said that he will try and play against
this d5 pawn here and hopefully make use
of the C file so rook the c1 dubov is
first get his rook over to the C file
and now Queen captures and b3 with a
captures and of course rook F the c8
country in whites rook and C 1 and here
dubov goes for rook to c4 so a very
useful idea most of the times you want
to make a nice rook lift here and of
course if black needs the capture then
you will just fix your pawn structure
will be captures in C 3 so 9 to the d7
Nakamura wants to go night to b6 the
force do both the Train and c8 rook F 2
c1
dubov doubles up and only now Knight to
b6 attacking and defending so rook
captures with check rope captures rook
captures and Knight captures so the
rooks are off the board and Nakamura
will now try and play against the the
doubled pawns here he does have two
points on the Queen side so he will try
to pick up one of them and then maybe
create a passport
so g4 Baidu both a very strong move as
it weakens the e4 pawn so obviously we
want to capture here and then put
pressure on this pawn nakamura grabs F
captures Bishop characters in mountain
Knight the beasts ex putting pressure on
the d5 pawn so there should be back to
g3 not not much you can do about this
but instead of going for the d5 one
which is for the moment impossible if
you capture then just brush off the e6
check picks it up first night the h4
just going for Knight to f3 check to
grab more space or the force do both to
give up the bishop pair so Knights the
f4 by now by do both and Knight to f3
check we have King to g2 and now nice to
d2 finally the night finds its way all
the way to the b3 pawn and now we have
Bishop there 5 you could defend it with
Bishop to d1 but it is it is a very
passive square foot
that's a weird arrow passive square for
the bishop so instead we have Bishop to
f5 here trying to trade this point for
this pawn and the nakamura says that's
that's fine Knight character son b3 and
now by eliminating one of the points
here Nakamura will move this night and
start pushing these pawns at some point
you will create a passed pawn here so
Bishop captures on e4 and now Knight to
c4 the points are now ready to be pushed
we have Knights the d3 are also
defending the be to pawn which was under
attack and a five now nakamura starts
pushing his Queen side points now with
Bishop back to f3 and now comes b5 of
course a you continue pushing the pawns
we've pushed back the d1 putting
pressure on the night and the night B to
d2 now and here b3 keeping an eye on the
a4 squared and the problem for duble
here is that he is well his position is
worse of course but he's also thirty
seconds on the clock whereas Hikaru has
over five minutes
so Knight back the beestings by Hikaru
adding another defender to DA Foursquare
so now a 4 of course will be be an idea
and Knights the f4 by dubov
and now the kicker took some time here
he does have five minutes on the clock
calculating is it okay to push a four
and finally he goes for it a for the
past
has been created be captures we have the
big actress on a four and now you are
very very close to cleaning your pond so
do book needs to set up a defense here
and night goes back to be three a three
and now tonight's to be for guarding the
eight-year square however I hear
Nakamura just well there are a lot of
ways to continue playing this but
Nakamura just goes for the for the brute
force variation with night capture sandy
five he offers a night here but if you
capture the night than just a two and
well it just came over there's no no
getting back from this even though you
will lose the bishop here with Czech
it's it's it's perfectly fine there is
no Bishop to e5 since the pawn covers
that square you will not be able to
guard the a1 square so do both has to go
back Knights to a tube and now King to
f8 he car starts bringing the King into
the game
we have Bishop to a for not allowing it
and now Knight to e4 putting pressure on
the Bishop and here comes Bishop back to
b3 now attacking the knight Knight d2 c3
offering of course a trade of nights
here but now Knights the b4 dubov needs
to keep an eye on the a2 square so here
we have nice to d2 also possible is just
the d5 attacking this this night here
and you will be able to Queen the pawn
here however it's a rapid game you know
anything can go wrong for example
something like Knight captures a two and
then Bishop captures an ad you can give
up a piece here and then maybe maybe
even try to hold this you are down a
piece but you're up a pawn in a rapid
game who knows so Nakamura doesn't want
to give it above any chances he just
goes nights to d2 attacks the Bishop
Bishop back to e6 and only now d5 closes
the bishops defense of the a to pawn by
of the a2 square so now a 2 is coming
and there is nothing do both can do
about it so Knights the c2
he still needs to keep around the a1
square and night the c4 now we have
efore hoping for CalPERS and then to
eliminate the night here but now just a
2 we have a capture Sun d5 grabbing that
pawn but now comes Bishop to d6 blocking
the pawn offering a trade and well
there's not much doable
both can do here so pink the f3 was
played maybe better was just Bishop
captures here not allowing that King to
e7 move but dubov is extremely low on
time he's basically playing on increment
so King is 7 and now Bishop back to f5
we have nice the b5 Hikaru creating the
deadly threat and there's well there's
no way to avoid it or anything so Dougal
just goes back Bishop to d3 and now feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the absolute best winning move for
Hikaru while I give you a couple of
seconds so for those of you who are able
to do it congratulations on successfully
removing the defender of the a1 square
and for those of you who just wanna
enjoy the show it's nice to d4 check you
sacrifice tonight and then you just
promote the pawn there's no way to
prevent this if you move the King then
just captures and you promote the pawn
so double grab the night but now just a
one Queen Hikaru brings a queen enter
game and do both did try Knight f5 check
I had to create some threats here
there's a double attack here maybe if
you can get two pieces against the Queen
maybe you can create some sort of a
fortress but Hikaru just goes a king to
f6 and now there is not much to be done
here do go tried Bishop captures on c3
but now of course Bishop captures and g3
by Hikaru and it was in this position
and more 53 that Daniel do both resigned
the game and Hikaru gets back into the
match it's 1:1 now and we are going into
Game four you know with great suspense
so here you resign because well if knife
captors and g3 then you just go Queen c3
trick pick up the bishop there's this is
unplayable Queen against the bishop and
if instead after Bishop captures and g3
you go H captures with hopes of Queen C
3 and then 93 guarding the bishop then
block just captures the night and then
again Queen against the bishop
completely winning so after Bishop
captures and g3 he resigned in nakamura
is back in the match so that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Carl Ivor Anoush we're scum TV
Adelle Bowden Alexander decree and
Mathis Financial Corporation for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon most likely with the final game
of the match or maybe not the final
maybe we go into Armageddon as well so
thank you I will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day